[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Norbert Lehmann
für den Sport ein schönen guten Abend
auch von mir mehr als fünf Stunden
dauerte der Wahlkrimi in der Hauptstadt
heute
Regierungswechsel in Berlin CDU
landesschef Kai Wegner wird nach
mehreren Anläufen neuer Regierender
Bürgermeister
Richtungswahl in der Türkei rund 1,5
Millionen Türkinnen und Türken in
Deutschland können schon jetzt ihre
Stimme abgeben
und Buchmesse in Leipzig nach drei
Jahren Pause feiert die Stadt wieder
Deutschlands zweitgrößtes Lesefest
ein holpriger Start war das für den
neuen Regierenden Bürgermeister Berlins
erst im dritten Wahlgang bekam CDU
landesschef Kai Wegner genug Stimmen
unklar ist ob dann tatsächlich alle
Abgeordneten aus seiner großen Koalition
für ihn stimmten mit Kai Wegner ist zum
ersten Mal seit mehr als zwei
Jahrzehnten wieder ein CDU-Politiker
Regierender Bürgermeister in Berlin
Wegener ist gelernter
Versicherungskaufmann und dreifacher
Vater er saß 15 Jahre lang im Bundestag
seit 2019 ist er CDU-Landesvorsitzende
in Berlin insbesondere bei der SPD Basis
gab es bis zuletzt Vorbehalte gegen den
50-Jährigen Markus groß über den
Wahlkrimi
ich schwöre so war mir Gott helfen drei
Wahlgänge braucht kein Wegner bis er die
Eidesformel sprechen darf Jubel und
Applaus bei SPD und CDU Erleichterung
bei ihm und seinem Koalitionspartner
es geht heute ein Signal aus dass das
ein schwieriger Tag war aber am Ende
werden wir eine handlungsfähige
Landesregierung in Berlin haben die mit
den Stimmen der Koalition gewählt worden
ist 86 Stimmen hat diese Koalition und
86 Stimmen haben heute dann am Schluss
mit Ja gestimmt Berlins neuer
Regierungschef hat zuvor einen
dramatischen Tag erlebt in zwei
Wahlgängen krachen durchgefallen obwohl
schwarz-rot eine satte Mehrheit hat
Krisensitzung bei SPD und CDU wer hat
ihm die Stimme verweigert gegenseitige
Vorwürfe
das Teil der SPD ist ja auch
kommuniziert worden dass Kai Wegener für
sie ein Problem ist und da mache ich das
ein Stück weit auch fest ich kann nur
sagen ich hoffe dass kein Wegner jetzt
in diesen Minuten seine rein schießen
kann die entscheidende dritte Abstimmung
vor Spannung kaum zu übermieten 86 Jahre
Stimmen am Ende doch das wahldrama ist
damit noch nicht beendet die AFD
behauptet anschließend sie haben bewegen
damit ins Amt gewählt Tatsache oder
Finte überprüfen lässt sich das nicht
die Opposition empört das Kai Wagner
den Verdacht nicht mehr los wird dass er
jetzt mit den Stimmen der AFD zum
Regierenden Bürgermeister gewählt worden
ist das hätte schwarz rot niemals
riskieren dürfen ein denkwürdiger Tag
für den neuen im Roten Rathaus die
Glücksbotschaften der Schornsteinfeger
hätte er schon vorher brauchen können
ja ein denkwürdiger Wahltag Stefan
Merseburger in Berlin was bedeutet
dieser Auftakt für den neuen
Bürgermeister und die große Koalition
ja in der Tat es war ein turbulenter Tag
quälend lang und eine Demütigung für Kai
Wegner erst im dritten Wahlgang zum
Regierenden Bürgermeister gewählt dass
er im ersten wargang durchfallen würde
damit wurde ja gerechnet im Vorfeld aber
erst im dritten das ist eine schallende
Ohrfeige für Wegener und auch für Giffey
und für das Scheitern in den ersten
beiden Wahlgängen schieben sich CDU und
SPD gegenseitig die Schuld in die Schuhe
und dann kommt auch noch die AFD und
behauptet Wegener im dritten Wahlgang
zum Bürgermeister gewählt zu haben ist
ist eine geheime Wahl gewesen beweisen
kann man das nicht nur das Gegenteil
kann man eben auch nicht beweisen und
klar ist schon jetzt das destabilisiert
das schwarz-rote Bündnis zusätzlich
schon jetzt sagt die Opposition stellt
Sie infrage deswegen überhaupt
Mehrheiten für Gesetze organisieren kann
und schwarz rot war ja gestartet mit dem
Versprechen den Streit zu beenden eine
neue Kultur der Zusammenarbeit für der
Stadt zu etablieren doch das was wir
heute gesehen haben war ein Trauerspiel
ein kolossaler Fehlstart Dankeschön nach
Berlin Stefan Merseburger war das
die meisten von ihnen kennen das die
Kosten für wichtige
Vorsorgeuntersuchungen übernehmen in der
Regel die Krankenkassen viele Ärzte
bieten darüber hinaus aber
Zusatzangebote an sogenannte Igel
individuelle Gesundheitsleistungen sie
müssen selbst gezahlt werden wirklich
notwendig oder am Ende sogar schädlich
mit dieser Frage hat sich der aktuelle
igelreport befasst auch im Hinblick auf
longkowith Behandlungen
Sauerstofftherapie oder auch Blutwäsche
in vielen Arztpraxen wird dafür geworben
Hoffnung für lonkovit Patientinnen und
Patienten Kurzatmigkeit und
dauererschöpfung in den Griff zu kriegen
aber Vorsicht warnt der neue igelreport
das kann teuer werden und ob es wirklich
hilft ist unklar wir haben uns das
angeguckt und haben einfach keine
Studien gefunden aus denen sich ein
Nutzen oder Schaden ableiten ist das
heißt wir wissen nicht ob diese Therapie
wirkt und wir wissen auch nicht
inwiefern diese Therapien Schaden das
Geschäft mit individuellen
Gesundheitsleistungen so der Report
läuft auf hohem Niveau Umfang mehr als
eine Milliarde Euro pro Jahr jetzt
wurden 55 einzelne igeleistungen
bewertet bei keine einzigen ein
positiver nutzen zwei not tendenziell
positiv unklarer nutzen bei 24
tendenziell negativ 25 ganz negativ vier
wie der Ultraschall der Eierstöcke zu
Krebs Früherkennung der als igeleistung
am häufigsten in Frauenarzt Praxen
verkauft wird viele falsche Befunde so
der Report führten zu nicht notwendigen
Operationen Frauen werden vielfach
unnötig in Angst und Schrecken versetzt
wobei nicht bewiesen ist dass dadurch
insgesamt gesehen die Sterblichkeit an
Eierstockkrebs reduziert werden kann vor
einigen Jahren waren es vor allem die
über 50-Jährigen die igeleistungen in
Anspruch genommen haben jetzt sind es
zunehmend jüngere trotz fragwürdigen
nutzen
ob im Handwerk in der Kita der Pflege
oder in der IT-Branche in Deutschland
fehlen hunderttausende Fachkräfte die
Bundesregierung will gegensteuern und
die Hürden für Zuwanderung senken die
Wirtschaft ist dafür Union und AFD
dagegen über eine leidenschaftliche
Debatte im Bundestag Christiane hübscher
zwei Millionen offene Stellen das gehe
so nicht weiter sagt Innenministerin
väser im Bundestag und verspricht ein
modernes Fachkräfte Einwanderungsgesetz
der Fach
kräftemada Deutschland steht eben mit
allen Ländern im Konkurrenz um die
besten Köpfe künftig sollen ausländische
Fachkräfte mit zwei Jahren
Berufserfahrung nach Deutschland kommen
dürfen auch wenn ihr Abschluss hier noch
nicht anerkannt ist die Union hat Kritik
am Gesetz ihre Antwort auf nahezu alle
Fragen heißt die Anforderungen an die
Qualifikation zu reduzieren damit
verkehren sie es in eine Einwanderung
von minder qualifizierten das sei
ideologisch motivierte Blockadehaltung
der Union schimpfen Ampel Vertreter
zurück Christoph
auch immer wieder gegenüber denjenigen
die vielleicht hier hinkommen könnten um
uns auszunutzen ich glaube sie haben den
Kern eines Fachkräfte
einwanderungsgesetzes nicht verstanden
wenn ein Arbeitgeber einen Arbeitnehmer
findet kann uns doch als Staat völlig
egal sein wie der qualifiziert ist der
musste arbeiten können es muss so
einfach wie möglich gemacht werden mit
einem Punktesystem nach kanadischem
Vorbild sollen auch nicht EU-Ausländer
ohne Abschluss aber mit Potenzial kommen
dürfen die AFD dagegen sie wollen
keinerlei Sprachprüfungen mehr abhalten
lassen jeder kann kommen egal ob er ein
Wort Deutsch spricht oder nicht das
stärkt nicht diesen Zusammenhalt in
dieser Gesellschaft in wirdringen
brauchen das neue Fachkräfte
Einwanderungsgesetz tritt frühestens im
Dezember in Kraft
für türkische Staatsbürgerinnen und
Staatsbürger die in Deutschland leben
beginnt heute die Wahl möglicherweise
eine Schicksalswahl denn zum ersten Mal
nach 20 Jahren könnte Präsident Erdogan
scheitern mehr zum wahlauftakt in
Deutschland gleich zunächst zeigt Delia
Thomas wie das Ganze abläuft
insgesamt sind rund 61 Millionen
türkische Staatsbürger aufgefordert ein
neues Parlament und auch einen neuen
Präsidenten zu wählen
etwa 3 Millionen Wahlberechtigte leben
nicht in der Türkei sondern in der EU
fast die Hälfte davon in Deutschland
türkische Staatsbürger die in
Deutschland im Wählerverzeichnis
registriert sind können hier ihre Stimme
abgeben von heute an bis zum 9 mai
gewählt wird unter anderem in den
türkischen generalkonsulaten großer
Städte
die Stimmzettel werden dann in die
Türkei gebracht und dort mit ausgezählt
viele Jahre haben die türkischen
Staatsbürger in Deutschland mehrheitlich
Erdogan unterstützt nach aktuellen
Einschätzungen ist das noch immer so
damit kommt den Stimmen aus Deutschland
für Erdogan eine große Bedeutung zu
denn in der Türkei ist das Stimmungsbild
ein anderes danach könnte es am 14 mai
für Präsident Erdogan richtig knapp
werden entsprechend wichtig sind die
Stimmen aus dem Ausland Ina Baltes
berichtet
ein großer Ansturm am ersten wahlmorgen
im Konsulat in Köln eine deutliche
Mehrheit der Deutschtürken die sich uns
gegenüber äußern bekennt sich zu Erdogan
wenn Sie Ruhe in den der Türkei haben
wollen auf der Welt da muss der der
Erdogan muss in der Macht bleiben vor
ihm war alles schlecht danach war alles
bis hier sehr gut erdogan hat eine
starke Basis in Deutschland Massen
Wahlkampf wie 2014 ist hier inzwischen
verboten die Parteien werden leise um
Stimmen Erdogans Anhänger sind sie
gesichert viele Deutsche Türken sind ja
auch Fassung das nehme ich ihre Stimme
beispielsweise bei der deutschen
Regierung nicht so stark zur Geltung
kommt und wenn es dann den
Staatspräsidenten Erdogan geht
beziehungsweise Vertreter aus der Türkei
gibt die ihrer Stimme Geltung verleihen
das sind Sachen die werden natürlich von
den deutschen Türken begrüßt so
überzeugt der Erdogan bei der letzten
Wahl rund 65% der türkischen Wähler in
Deutschland diese Dominanz erwarten wir
bei diesen Wahl nicht gleichwohl gehen
wir davon aus dass Erde Ohren aber auch
die AKP in Deutschland auch wieder die
erste Partei sein wird aber nicht mit
einem dominanten Vorsprung auch die
Opposition rechnet sich in diesem Jahr
Chancen aus wir glauben fest daran dass
es diesmal klappt seit 21 Jahren regiert
die AKP wie regiert die indem die
Willkür Justiz ausübt
Menschenrechtsverletzungen Prognosen
sagen für den 14 Mai ein knappes Rennen
voraus damit könnten die Stimmen der
Deutsch Türken das Zünglein an der Waage
sein
in der Türkei hat sich AKP
Spitzenkandidat Erdogan offenbar eine
wahlkampfpause verordnet sein Umfeld
spricht von Magen und Darm Problemen
heute zeigte sich Erdogan nur per
Videokonferenz mit russlands Präsident
Putin die beiden Staatschefs waren bei
der Einweihung eines Atomkraftwerks
zugeschaltet am Dienstagabend hatte
Erdogan ein Fernsehinterview wegen
gesundheitlicher Probleme unterbrochen
zur Wahl in der Türkei gibt's auch ein
ZDF heute live gleich um 19:30 Uhr zu
sehen auf unseren Social Media Kanälen
und über die ZDF heute App
die Bundeswehr hat nach ihrer
Evakuierungsaktion den Sudan verlassen
im Rahmen der Rückverlegung konnte die
Luftwaffe weitere 65 Menschen in
Sicherheit bringen im Sudan selbst gehen
die Kämpfe trotz vereinbarter Waffenruhe
weiter und weiten sich aus auch in der
Region davor im Westen des Landes hat es
Angriffe gegeben
nach Afghanistan vor fast zwei Jahren
haben die Taliban die Macht an sich
gerissen seitdem hat sich die humanitäre
Krise in dem Land weiter verschärft
in Afghanistan leben laut Schätzungen
rund 40 Millionen Menschen die meisten
davon in bitterer Armut es fehlt am
nötigsten vor allem Essen ist knapp fast
die Hälfte der Bevölkerung leidet nach
UN-Angaben unter akutem Hunger aus Kabul
berichtet Katrin Eugendorf
chaotisches Szenen vor der Ausgabestelle
des Welt Ernährungsprogramms der
Vereinten Nationen aus Angst keine
Lebensmittel mehr zu erhalten drängen
die Frauen herein
sie haben uns gesagt dass die Hilfe die
wir bekommen jetzt eingestellt wird die
Situation ist nicht gut die Frauen die
hier in der Schlange stehen haben
wirtschaftliche Probleme
Philipp Kropf der Sprecher des World
Food program zeigt mir die
Nahrungsmittel die an die Familien
verteilt werden doch lange reicht der
Vorrat nicht mehr
kein neues Geld mehr erhalten
wir mussten die Unterstützung von 13
Millionen Menschen in diesem Monat auf 5
Millionen Menschen reduzieren und wenn
kein neues Geld reinkommt dann ist Ende
Mai die letzte distribution in
Afghanistan mehr als 19 Millionen
Menschen leiden unter Hunger
es gibt Lebensmittel in Afghanistan nur
immer weniger Menschen können sich diese
Leisten die internationalen
Hilfsorganisationen hier vor Ort
versuchen die Hungerkatastrophe zu
vermeiden doch ihre Arbeit wird hier
immer weiter erschwert seitdem die
Taliban verfügt haben dass Frauen nicht
mehr für sie arbeiten dürfen stehen
Hilfsorganisationen vor der Frage ob sie
ihre Arbeit einstellen sollen wir können
diese Millionen hungernde Menschen
inklusive der Hälfte Frauen und Mädchen
und ready most Wanderung jetzt nicht im
Stich lassen es ist ihre einzige
Perspektive um ihren Familien das
Überleben zu sichern sagen die Frauen
zurück nach Deutschland da gibt es neue
Erkenntnisse zur Messerattacke von
Duisburg der mutmaßliche Täter steht
auch unter dringendem Tatverdacht Tage
zuvor einen 35-Jährigen getötet zu haben
darauf deuteten DNA-Spuren am Tatort hin
so die Ermittler der 26-Jährige Syrer
soll vor gut einer Woche in einem
Fitnessstudio vier Menschen mit einer
Stichwaffe schwer verletzt haben
möglicherweise aus islamistischen
Motiven er sitzt in Untersuchungshaft
mehr als sieben Wochen ist die Amok Tat
auf eine Gemeinde der Zeugen Jehovas in
Hamburg her nun ermittelt die
Staatsanwaltschaft gegen einen
Mitarbeiter der Waffenbehörde wegen des
Verdachts der fahrlässigen Tötung er
soll Informationen über den psychischen
Zustand des Täters nicht weitergeleitet
haben außerdem laufen Untersuchungen
gegen drei Mitglieder eines schießklubs
sie sollen dem Täter ohne bestandene
Prüfung zum Waffenschein verholfen haben
der 35-Jährige hatte bei einem
Gottesdienst der Zeugen Jehovas sieben
Menschen und dann sich selbst erschossen
und jetzt was ganz anderes endlich ist
wieder Trubel auf der Treppe zur
Leipziger Buchmesse drei Jahre lang war
wegen Corona Zwangspause jetzt können
lesebegeisterte wieder schwelgen vier
Tage die für Leipzig die Welt bedeuten
so titelte heute die Frankfurter
Allgemeine Zeitung Thomas Bersch hat
mehr
der Neustart der Buchmesse ist geglückt
über den ganzen Tag drängeln sich die
Besucher schon gestern startete auch das
Lesefest Leipzig liest
mit einem Poetry Slam Battle zwischen
Deutschland und dem Gastland Österreich
endlich wieder Kultur nach drei Jahren
das ist so ein richtiger Enthusiasmus
dabei und ich freue mich dass wir wieder
die Kulturlandschaft aus Leipzig zeigen
können die Messe findet sich bei ihrem
Neustart in einer anderen Buch und
Lesewelt wieder so versammeln sich
inzwischen auf der Videoplattform tiktok
Millionen junge Leserinnen und Leser die
unter dem Schlagwort burgtalk Videos
über Bücher milliardenfach liken und
weiter schicken Verlage müssen nun dort
auch mit und reden solche Videos selbst
doch noch nicht für alle Zielgruppen und
Genres wir sehen natürlich auch oft
Fantasy die wir persönlich in unserem
Programm nicht so haben aber eben die
Raum kommt die romantischen Komödien
daher kommt der Begriff die Romans
Liebesgeschichten die auch so ein
bisschen auch ein bisschen Spice
enthalten das sehen wir viel auf tiktok
Leipzig versteht sich als Messe fürs
Publikum zum Zuhören nachdenken und mit
diskutieren in Tagen wie diesen nicht
nur über Literatur sondern auch über
Krieg Klima und Meinungsfreiheit wenn
sie Verlage mit dieser Literatur hier im
weiten sozusagen einen weiteren Sinne
auf die angekommen dann sind diese
Debatten virulent und sie werden auf der
Messe auch geführt dazu ist eine
Buchmesse da an die Ausstellerzahlen vor
Corona wird die Messe noch nicht
anknüpfen auf das Publikums Echo
hingegen darf man gespannt sein
also auf nach Leipzig aber vorher noch
Fußball nicht nur bei uns ist die
meisten
Meisterschaft
Dortmund oder Bayern in England Arsenal
oder City gestern Abend das Topspiel
zwischen dem Tabellenführer aus London
und dem Titelverteidiger aus Manchester
ja und der gewann daheim eindrucksvoll
mit 14:1 gemeinsam der Jubel umgedreht
die Rollen von Erling hardern und Kevin
de Bräune der lange Norweger lässt beste
Chancen aus aber brilliert als
Vorbereiter für denjenigen der ihm
normalerweise die Bälle auflegt der
Bräune zum frühen 1:0 für ManCity
Holland mit viel Platz um den Ball nach
vorne zu treiben wieder passt er auf den
kongenialen Partner das 3:0 10 Minuten
nach der Pause kurz vor Schluss hardern
ohne Haarreif mit ungebändigte
Haarpracht immer noch ohne seinen
ersehnten 33 Liga Treffer der Bräune
inzwischen ausgewechselt und siehe da
nun trifft Holland zum 4:1 Endstand Man
City kommt bis auf zwei Zähler an
arsenal heran und hat noch zwei Spiele
mehr zum Punkten
und wichtige Personal die hierzulande
bei einem der beiden Titel Aspiranten in
der Bundesliga den BVB Marco Reus bleibt
Dortmund erhalten der 33 Jahre alte
Kapitän hat seinen Vertrag verlängert um
ein Jahr bis 2024
und in Italien da ist der Kampf um Platz
1 schon so gut wie gelaufen in der Serie
Arkan Neapel am Sonntag vorzeitig
Meister werden zum ersten Mal seit 1990
die Fußball verrückte Stadt befindet
sich aber längst im Ausnahmezustand
seit Wochen sind blau und weiß die
vorherrschenden Farben in Neapel
Straßenbild allgegenwärtig natürlich
Diego Armando Maradona der den Club vor
33 Jahren zum letzten Meistertitel
geführt hatte am Titel in dieser Saison
haben die Neapolitaner keinen Zweifel
in den vergangenen Jahren waren wir oft
nicht dran aber keiner hat sich getraut
über den Titel zu reden in diesem Jahr
da machen wir es einfach mal andersherum
haften 17 Punkten Vorsprung führt Neapel
in der Liga vor Lazio Rom bei noch
sieben Spielen ist der große Triumph
also nur noch eine Frage der Zeit und
bis die gekommen ist feiert sich Neapel
einfach schon mal warm
das war es vom Sport danke schön zum
Schluss eine Geschichte von großen
Tieren und kleinen Tieren dieses hier
ist nur einen Millimeter groß eine neue
Wespenart mit geheimnisvollen Borsten am
Hinterteil die vielleicht als Säge
dienen seit heute heißt das Insekt
offiziell avanockmus kretschmoney
benannt nach baden-Württembergs
Ministerpräsident Winfried Kretschmann
die Entdeckerin der Wespe hatte sich für
den grünen Politiker als Namensgeber
entschieden wegen seines Engagements für
die 48
morgen wird's nass die Details hat
gleich erst den terli im Wetter
Christian Sievers begrüßte ihm heute
journal um viertel vor zehn und wir sind
morgen wieder da alles Gute ihnen danke
für Ihr Interesse und einen schönen
Abend noch tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter ein neues Tief
nähert sich von Westen und dessen
Fronten sorgen für regen zum Beispiel
diese Warmfront die in der Nacht
aufzieht und danach kommt die Kaltfront
und dann gibt es auch Schauer und
Gewitter das Ganze im Detail in der
Nacht also von Südwesten her viele
Wolken und Regen im Osten ist es
trockenteilstern klar die Temperaturen
gehen dort zurück bis auf -1° hier ist
es am kältesten in der Nacht 10 Grad im
Südwesten dort am mildesten ja am
Vormittag den sich die Wolken bis etwa
zur Elbe aus ansonsten östlich davon
zeigt sich durchaus die Sonne aber sonst
eben recht viel Regen dabei zum
Nachmittag schieben sich die Wolken
weiter in den Osten und einzig Richtung
Ostsee bleibt ist trocken sonst aber zum
Nachmittag also auch mit Schauern und
Gewittern bei höchsten Temperaturen bis
20 Grad ganz im Westen Deutschlands und
in der norddeutschen Tiefe Ebene teils
11 bis 12 Grad hier ist das partiell am
kältesten die nächsten Tage Samstag
lässt der Regen allmählich nach hier im
Osten noch etwas 12 bis 20 Grad Sonntag
schon trocken und 1 Mai im Süden
durchwachsen ein schöner Abend